en el vídeo anterior vimos que la
frecuencia de vibración se puede ver
como la oscilación de un resorte y que
depende de dos cosas depende de que la
constante elástica o constante de fuerza
del resorte y de la masa reducida que es
igual a la masa 1 m 1 por m2 / m 1 + m2
aquí tenemos nuestro enlace dibujado
como un resorte con m1 y m2 en cada
extremo entonces si aumentamos la
constante elástica o de fuerza
eso significa que aumentamos la fuerza
del enlace y obviamente aumentamos la
frecuencia aumentamos la frecuencia de
la vibración del enlace así que un
enlace fuerte vibra más rápido que un
enlace débil y si disminuimos la masa
reducida
entonces la frecuencia de vibración
aumenta
el primer vídeo dijimos que la
frecuencia o radiación era absorbida por
una molécula coincide con la frecuencia
de vibración de un enlace y hablamos
sobre la relación entre la frecuencia y
el número de onda el número de onda es
igual a la frecuencia entre la velocidad
de la luz en centímetros por segundo
entonces si tomamos todo esto y lo
dividimos entre la velocidad de la luz
se obtenemos el número de onda esta es
una buena forma de calcular el número de
onda para encontrar las señales en la
espectroscopía y r
muy bien otra cosa que necesitamos hacer
para que nos queden las unidades del
número de onda porque aquí la masa
reducida está en gramos necesitamos
pasar esto a unidades de masa atómica
así que necesitamos dividir entre el
número de abogados el número de onda es
igual a uno entre dos vice por la raíz
cuadrada de k entre la masa reducida y
para obtener las unidades que queremos
tenemos que dividir la masa reducida
entre el número de avogadro que es igual
a 6.0 todos por 10 a la 23 y esto es
igual a 1 entre 2 bis por la raíz
cuadrada la dibujaré más larga de la
constante de fuerza entre la masa
reducida
el número de avogadro que lo pasamos al
numerador 6.02 por 10 a la 23 calculemos
la raíz cuadrada del número de abogados
tenemos raíz cuadrada de 6.02 por 10 a
la 23 esto es igual a 7.76 por 10 a la
11 nos queda que el número de onda es
igual a 7.76 por 10 a la 11 entre 2 pi
por c que es la velocidad de la luz en
centímetros por segundo y es igual a 3
por 10 a la 10
la raíz cuadrada de la constante de
fuerza
entre la masa reducida calculemos esta
parte necesitamos dividir este número
entre 2 después entre pi y finalmente
entre la velocidad de la luz en
centímetros por segundo 3 por 10 a lápiz
y eso es igual a 4.12 entonces el número
de onda es igual a 4.12 por la raíz
cuadrada de k entre la masa reducida
esta es una ecuación más pequeña para
obtener el número de onda en el que
esperamos ver las señales de los
diferentes enlaces entonces acá es la
constante de elasticidad o de fuerza y
está dada en dinas por centímetros y la
masa reducida está dada en unidades de
masa atómica hagamos algunos cálculos
empecemos con un enlace carbono
primero calculemos la masa reducida la
masa reducida es igual a la masa atómica
del carbono que es 12 por la masa del
hidrógeno que es uno entre 12 más
1 este cálculo lo hicimos en el vídeo
anterior y obtuvimos 0.900 23 ahora
vamos a sustituir este valor en la
ecuación del número de onda el número de
onda es igual a 4.12 por la raíz
cuadrada de la constante de fuerza para
un enlace simple estamos hablando de un
enlace carbono hidrógeno así que la
constante de fuerza para este caso es 5
por 10 a las cinco minas por centímetros
entre la masa reducida que es igual a
cero punto 923 usemos la calculadora
tenemos
5 por 10 a las 5 / 0.900 23 después
sacamos la raíz cuadrada de esto y este
resultado lo multiplicamos por cuatro
punto 12 esto es igual a 3 mil 32 el
número de onda es igual a 3000 32 1 /
centímetros si analizamos un espectro y
r encontraremos que hay una señal en un
número de onda muy cercano a este así
que esta es una buena aproximación ahora
hagamos el cálculo para un enlace
carbono oxígeno todavía tenemos un
enlace simple pero esta vez tenemos
carbono y oxígeno así que la masa
reducida cambia pero la constante de
fuerza es la misma porque en ambos casos
hay un enlace simple y supondremos que
tienen la misma fuerza
entonces la más reducida para este caso
es igual a la masa del carbono que es 12
por la masa del oxígeno que es 16 entre
12 y 16 usemos la calculadora tenemos 12
por 16 que es igual a 192 entre 28 esto
es igual a 6.9 la masa reducida es igual
a 6.9 ahora calculemos el número de onda
tenemos 4.12 por la raíz cuadrada de
usemos el mismo número de acá 5 por 10 a
las 5 porque tenemos un enlace simple
entre la masa reducida que es igual a
6.9 usemos la calculadora tenemos 5 por
10 a las cinco en
y 6.9 a ese resultado le sacamos la raíz
cuadrada y luego multiplicamos por 4.12
esto es igual a 1.109 el número de onda
es igual a 1.109 1 entre centímetros
ahora comparemos los dos números de onda
que fue lo que hicimos bueno cambiamos
el hidrógeno por un oxígeno así que
aumentamos la masa del segundo atom y
qué pasó con el número de onda observen
que el número de onda bajó de 3 mil 32 a
1.109 porque la masa reducida cambio de
0.900 23 a 6.9 así que aumentamos la
masa reducida y disminuimos la
frecuencia o número de onda entonces
este es el valor aproximado en el que
encontraremos la señal para él en la
ese simple carbono oxígeno ahora hagamos
el cálculo para un doble enlace carbono
carbono primero calculemos la masa
reducida que es igual a 12 por 12 entre
12 + 12 y esto es igual a 6 ahora vamos
a sustituirlo en nuestra ecuación el
número de onda es igual a 4.12 por la
raíz cuadrada de cuál es la constante de
fuerza bueno ahora tenemos un doble
enlace carbono carbón y podemos suponer
que tiene el doble de fuerza de un
enlace simple así que multiplicamos este
número por 2 y eso es igual a 10 por 10
a las 5 ésta es sólo una aproximación no
es el número exacto pero lo podemos usar
así usemos la calculadora tenemos 10 por
10 a las 5 entre 6 a eso le sacamos la
raíz cuadrada y después multiplicamos
por cuatro punto 12 esto es igual a mil
682 el número de onda es igual a mil 682
y es en donde encontraremos una señal
para un doble enlace carbono carbono en
el espectro y er hagamos uno más ahora
veamos un triple enlace carbono carbono
ya sabemos que la masa reducida es igual
a 6 pero la constante de fuerza es
diferente entonces el número de onda es
igual a 4.12 por la raíz cuadrada de
cuál es la constante de fuerza bueno
esta fue la constante para el doble
enlace pero como en este caso tenemos un
triple enlace entonces multiplicamos 3
por 5 por 10 a las 5 y nos queda 15 por
10 a las 5 entre 6 usemos la calculadora
tenemos 15 por 10 a las 5 entre 6 a esto
le sacamos la raíz cuadrada eso nos da
500 y luego multiplicamos por 4.12 esto
es igual a 2060 el número de onda es
igual a 2060 si comparamos los últimos
dos ejemplos observen que únicamente
aumentamos el valor de acá eso es lo
único que cambió aumentamos la constante
de fuerza porque un triple enlace es más
fuerte que un doble enlace y qué pasó
con la frecuencia o número de onda bueno
el número de onda aumentó así que al
aumentar acá aumenta la frecuencia
finalmente graphic hemos esto en un
espectro
r empecemos con la señal del enlace
simple carbono hidrógeno se encuentra
aproximadamente en 3 mil 32 entonces 3
mil 32 se encuentra por aquí aquí es
aproximadamente en donde encontraremos
la señal para un enlace simple carbono
hidrógeno y si pensamos en las regiones
del espectro
r en algún lugar de esta región
encontraremos un enlace con el hidrógeno
dijimos que esta es la señal para un
enlace carbono hidrógeno pero lo podemos
generalizar diciendo que puede ser
cualquier otro átomo que tenga un enlace
con un hidrógeno porque el hidrógeno
tiene la masa atómica más pequeña y eso
provoca que la frecuencia aumente ahora
veamos el enlace carbono oxígeno aquí
tenemos un número de onda igual a 1.109
una gran diferencia aunque sigue siendo
un enlace simple 1.109 se encuentra
aproximadamente aquí y corresponde al
enlace carbono oxígeno esta es una
región en la que tenemos un enlace
simple pero no tenemos hidrógeno
entonces esta es la región que
corresponde al enlace simple y esta
región corresponde al enlace con
hidrógeno ahora vamos con el doble
enlace carbono carbono nos dio un número
de onda de aproximadamente mil 682 mil
682 se encuentra aproximadamente aquí
aquí es donde encontraremos la señal de
un doble enlace carbono carbón y esta es
la región que corresponde al doble
enlace así que aproximadamente en esta
región del espectro
esperaremos encontrar señales que
correspondan a un doble enlace
finalmente la última región corresponde
al triple enlace ya calculamos que el
número de onda esté aproximadamente 2060
y se encuentra por aquí aquí
encontraremos la región del triple
enlace que va desde 2100 hasta 2.300
aproximadamente es más pequeña pero esto
nos da una idea de las diferentes
regiones esta es la región que
corresponde al triple enlace espero que
esto les ayude a entender por qué
obtuvimos diferentes números de onda
como ya vimos tiene que ver con dos
cosas con la constante de fuerza y con
la masa reducida si tomamos en cuenta
esos dos factores podemos saber en donde
aparecerá la señal para los
estiramientos de estos enlaces
así es como podemos conocer el número de
onda que nos ayudará a leer el espectro
y er